20.20 hatte ich zeit zum musikhören und
hat viel gespielt habe viel von den
alten sachen gehört songs gehört bei
denen man tanzen will obwohl man
vielleicht gar nicht im club gehen kann
und feiern gehen kann sie haben ja alle
gezwungenermaßen ein bisschen mehr zeit
zu hause es gab die möglichkeit sich
zurück zu besinnen auf ältere sachen
leute haben sich einfach im lockdown
inspirieren lassen und diese energie
kann man halt dann beim hören auch ein
bisschen aufnehmen und vieles wurde
dadurch einfach auch ein bisschen
bisschen erträglicher gewissen corona ja
[Musik]
ja mein song des jahres ist diana von
billy joel eher zufällig bin ich wieder
auf den zaun gestoßen ist eigentlich
eher schon klassiker von früher eine
schauspielerin hat ihnen gesungen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob der song vielleicht in
einem anderen jahr eine andere bedeutung
für mich gehabt hätte aber in diesem
jahr war der song natürlich etwas
spezieller weil der song ein ganz
ruhiges tempo hat irgendwie sehr langsam
ist und auch der songtext natürlich
davon handelt dass man locker und
einfach runter kommen sollen ein
bisschen wir sind ja irgendwie dazu
verleitet die ganze zeit immer mehr zu
machen immer mehr zu wollen
und genau in diesem jahr ging das halt
eben nicht so wirklich so dass ihr das
mein lieblingslied 2020 vor allem ein
lieblingsvideo gleich vor allem wegen
dieser szene die viele bestimmt noch aus
ihrer jugend kennen in meinem alter
eigentlich sitzt in dieser szene will
smith auf diesen thron der sich dreht
das ist aus dem intro von dem prinz von
bel-air will smith will smith will smith
will smith will smith also ein jogger
lukas zitiert in diesem lied eben
mehrfach eine stelle aus einem interview
dass will smith gegeben hat und er sagt
dass er als kind mal eine mauer bauen
sollte für seinen vater und dann so ein
bisschen gemerkt hat okay wenn du so ein
riesiges ziel vor dir hast dann musst du
dich wirklich auf ganz viele kleine
einzelne aufgaben konzentrieren einfach
auf jeden einzelnen stein und das fand
ich eigentlich auch so ein ganz coole
analogie zu diesem chor o na ja also
mein song des jahres 2020 ist genau eine
minute daniel heim die sängerin hat den
eigentlich geschrieben als sie von der
tour wieder gekommen ist und in eine
depression verfallen ist und im video
gibt es auch so eine szene wo sie im
nebel ist und ihre beiden schwestern sie
dann aus diesem nebel versuchen zu
befreien
und ich habe das ein bisschen auf diese
situation im locker und übertragen weil
da war man dann halt auch irgendwann
einfach drin und konnte nichts dagegen
machen und musste sich den sozusagen
hingeben
[Musik]
you look good to me von oscar peterson
aus den 60er jahren einen jazz klassiker
der vor 25 jahren ziemlich genau auch
mein einstieg in die jazz musik war zu
beginn ist es noch mal ganz wirklich
einfache wunderschöne melodie nachher
geht das stück unfassbar ab mit diesem
trio aus klavier schlagzeug und bass da
ist soviel kindlicher spielfreude drin
kreativität so viel swing soviel
unprätentiöses spiel was für mich in
diesem jahr einfach bei diesem stück so
toll ist das bringt was rüber was 2020
definitiv ansonsten gefehlt hat nämlich
leichtigkeit und mein chance gerade
nicht blocken von black los wollte nur
raus und ich mache heute geschäft von
gold meine zehen eis taut stets mein
wort kann dich
wir brauchen mein kopf bis sie gebrochen
mein herz ist
ja mein 20 20 war sehr plastisch vor
allem deutschrap wie man hört der song
obwohl man es vielleicht nicht sofort
hört es eigentlich in seinem
motivierender song der warm ist türkisch
und bedeutet weiter das heißt in dem
song geht es darum immer weiterzumachen
sich nicht von seinem zielen abbringen
zu lassen immer seinen träumen hinterher
zu gehen und ich glaube gerade jetzt in
dieser corona zeit ist der song bzw war
für mich ein sehr motivierende ein
tolles lied von einer tollen platz und
ja es ist die musik die mich mutig mein
leben begleitet durch mein ganzes leben
begleitet mich bruce springsteen der
mann ist wie ich finde extrem vielseitig
für traurige zeiten im leben für
euphorische und auch für die mischung
und dieses no surrender hat schwung und
es ist ein durchhalte die im besten
sinne mit augenzwinkern
mir macht es freude in diesem corona ja
besonders
[Musik]
wayne mit brain brain und
ja also muss ich mehr sagen ist
natürlich das hammer lied des jahres
weil es vom rhythmus schon so reinzieht
weil es ein total mitreißt und weil man
am ende überhaupt keine schlechte laune
mehr haben kann
also ich finde es gibt genug depri musik
auf der welt wenn ich drei chöre oder
sowas oder bruce springsteen oder so
jetzt bruce da kriege ich die krise
also wenn man sich dieses video paar mal
anguckt und einfach mit zum oder
mitsingen sofern man in der lage ist so
hoch zu kommen
tönis kamen in der armee wenn man das
tut dann ist man einfach in einer ganz
anderen sphäre und das schaffen nur
diese beiden die holiday inn ist einer
meiner lieblingssongs in dieser zeit
diese last und diese dieses elend von
dem sie sinkt das hat natürlich mit
ihrer lebensgeschichte zu tun die
ziemlich heftig ist aber eben auch mit
der lage der schwarzen bevölkerung in
dieser zeit in den 30er jahren und das
ist eigentlich eine ganz gute verbindung
zu diesem jahr denn auch in diesem jahr
gab es ja wieder ein schrei nach
gerechtigkeit in der schwarzen
bevölkerung amerikas
ja und ich finde ihr gelingt das
ziemlich gut den blues auf so eine serie
fort vorwärts gewandte ebene zu bringen
und das ganze auch etwas aufzulockern
und und erfreulicher und erträglicher zu
machen und deshalb nicht dass das ein
ganz schöner corona sein
[Musik]
ist noch nicht losgegangen ja ich bin
nie beliebig im prinzip born to run war
es nicht ungesetzlich falsch